[Music]
everyone loves a great villain however
nowadays there seems to be this
preconceived notion that in order for a
villain in a TV show or movie to be
interesting that villain must be
sympathetic or hold a belief that what
he or she is doing is morally just in
other words no villain can think that
they are the bad guy and if they did
they wouldn't be very interested and to
an extent I both agree and disagree with
that statement so I put up a poll on my
Twitter asking my followers who their
favorite villain was the options were
Frieza cell majin buu and zama suit with
over 2,000 votes cast than almost half
the votes Frieza won despite being in
the running with the sympathetic zama
suit however I don't think that really
proves anything two of the most popular
villains to emerge from Phil last year
were sympathetic Black Panthers kill
monger and infinity wars Thanos however
in recent years I've seen far more
sympathetic villains propagator screens
and a significant decline in the number
of pure evil ones which leads me to
believe that there's a misunderstanding
in her book creating character arcs kam
Weiland writes about the flat character
arc and how that character while he or
she doesn't develop personally changes
the world and characters around him or
her Goku is a positive flat mark and so
changes characters and the world around
him for the better but in the case of
Frieza he is a fantastic example of the
negative flat one that doesn't change or
develop but does change and manipulate
the world and characters around him for
the worse
however to find out what makes a great
flat arc villain like freeze a tick we
must first discuss what makes the most
popular villain arc in fiction so
successful the sympathetic or negative
arc villain the most common arc found in
fiction nowadays surrounding a villain
in a given story is the negative
character arc negative our characters
are those who through circumstance
personal experience or intervention have
become morally reprehensible individuals
through their expressed motivations we
the audience can clearly understand the
path they took to arrive where they
currently are this creates a more
realistic world as well as a great sense
of morality overall this can lead the
audience to better respect that in some
cases agree with the villains
motivations creating a more relatable
and as a result a more believable
character overall characters like Light
Yagami from Death Note and zama suit
from Dragon Ball super demonstrate this
arc perfectly since acai
the same scriptwriting Trobe can be
observed in positive character arms too
only it happens in Reverse instead of
overcoming a lie they believe the
negative character arc oftentimes sees a
villain develop a light to believe this
usually works well acting as a foil or
contrast to the main characters positive
arc development and this is where the
flat negative arc of Frieza differs from
conventional negative our characters he
doesn't develop from good to bad
he's a maliciously consistent psychopath
the hostile is a tamari bakunawa scribe
Bharat Oaxaca is rocoto that they kill
[Music]
Vox a Vegeta which emits a 7 in Robert
MCI's books story he writes a
protagonist and his story can only be as
intellectually fascinating and
emotionally compelling as the forces of
antagonism make them in the same way a
character like Goku changes the world
around him for the better while not
changing himself Frieza is a negative
flat-out character that changes the
world around him for the worse
he enslaves civilizations and enrolls
soldiers to do his bidding across the
universe where his presence is felt it's
an established trope that Goku uses
mercy and example to bring people to his
way of thinking
whereas Frieza utilizes fear and
manipulation to change people for the
worse because of who their characters
are Goku can't influence Frieza to be
good and Frieza can't influence Goku to
be bad q anjaneyasana mushi do Kyoto
Monica in John troubies book the anatomy
of story he writes you must see your
opponent's structural in terms of his
function in the story a true opponent
not only wants to prevent the hero from
achieving his desires but is competing
with the hero for that same goal find
the deepest level of conflict between
them ask yourself what is the most
important thing they are fighting about
Goku and the others travel dynamic to
obtain the planets Dragon Balls so that
they can wish Tien
ciaossu Yamcha and piccolo back to life
however freezes short-term motivation is
to gather the Dragon Balls too and thus
is in direct competition with the heroes
to achieve the same scenario this is the
organic reason both Goku and Frieza meet
if we go even deeper
Goku desires to fight Frieza because he
wants to prove that he is stronger than
him on the other side of the coin Frieza
is fighting Goku because he needs to be
the Emperor of the universe to show that
he is the strongest we learn exactly
what Frieza is about through his very
first introductory scene discovered by
Gohan and krillen Frieza flanked by his
henchmen holding in their possession
Dragon Balls begin what is a
surprisingly civil dialogue with the
namekians living there however the
moment resistance is met Frieza politely
asserts that if he plans to remain
silent
he will
have to die again intimidation is how
freezer gets his way here the entire
conversation between the elder namekian
and Frieza is conducted with a thick
tension in the air it's as if the entire
conversation is being carried out to
amuse Frieza
and for him to flex his cloud over the
villagers you might notice while
watching or reading this scene that it's
not entirely dissimilar to the opening
scene of inglorious basterds directed by
Quentin Tarantino this scene depicts a
French home being interrogated by the
Nazis which the lead interrogator
otherwise known as the Jew hunter is
much like Frieza coy playful with a
murderous streak what's more is that
both scenes seem to end in the same way
the Nazis haven't gotten what they came
for and one Jew escaping the clutches of
the invading Nazis the parallels between
Hitler and Frieza are quite apparent
Frieza is quite literally a racist he
believes that Saiyans are insignificant
nothing's that couldn't possibly measure
up to someone as sophisticated as he
neither mentally nor physically however
at the same time he is plagued by the
legend of the super saiyan which led him
to destroy an entire race of valuable
assets to his cause while this took
place goku was were the only Saiyans
that survived the attempted extinction a
Saiyan that happens to firmly hold the
belief that anyone can be better than
they are if they try hard enough
directly flying in the face of freezes
firmly held ideology similarly power
levels were introduced into the series
to reinforce this false narrative that
your power level is your value your
ranking in the world that you can never
change
and during the story time and time again
those that believe that narrative were
proven wrong time and time again
[Music]
for a villain to be a force in your
story he or she needs to have more power
than the hero but that isn't limited to
traditional power like strength or
resources for example zammis who was
more sly and cunning than those around
him and thus got as far as he did Frieza
was ruthless and smart you get the
picture but the villain can't just have
power he needs to have personality a
sort of charisma we find ourselves
rooting for Frieza not because we agree
with his motivations or goals but
because we respect his ethic in
attaining them Frieza is incredibly
tenacious he's also very pragmatic and
cunning these are traits which create
incredible character moments also many
of which were on display during freezes
brief antihero run in determined to
power where Frieza assumed a position
Vegeta was enduring his fight with the
ginyu force fighting against a common
enemy
however unlike Vegeta because of who
Frieza is a flat negative character he
reverted back to his mantra immediately
after through sadistic arrogant and
playful into the mix and you have
yourself a very entertaining character
this is why Frieza is on a fundamental
level
perfect for a story like Dragonball that
has a main character like coke Frieza
punishes those who stand up to him who
fight him and juxtapose to this Goku
celebrates those that are strong freezes
villainous motivation fundamentally
reflects but disagrees with the hero's
motivation Goku and this is what makes
their eventual clash all the more
satisfying and boy do they clash now
makes a Minato Mirai
I need get on in it in the book story
Robert McKee writes true character is
revealed in the choices a human being
makes under pressure the greater the
pressure the deeper the revelation the
truer the choice to the characters
essential nature what this means is if a
character is put under pressure then the
choices he or she makes are closer and
more honest to what their true nature is
Frieza is a tremendous pressure in this
scene in which because of the pressure
only Frieza can apply Goku does possibly
one of the most selfless things he does
in the entire series the kaio-ken times
20 putting his entire life at risk for a
chance to take Frieza out additionally
when Frieza is revived and forced to
train to be competitive in resurrection
death
Goku is directly bringing out the best
in Freeza Freeza does some of his best
work when interacting with Goku and Goku
to some of his best work while
interacting with Frieza
because of the nature of their
respective arcs they elevate and magnify
each other's personalities one last but
important thing I want to touch on
regarding freezes characterization is
his ability to exploit Goku's greatest
weakness he does this three times
throughout the story once on Namek
Frieza begs for mercy and Goku obliges
ones in resurrection F Frieza exploits
go whose guard being put down and once
in the afterlife when he bargains with
Goku to get his life back in exchange
for a chance to fight him once again no
character in the entire series has
manipulated Goku like Frieza has done
Frieza could have been written like a
tragic character one that through horrid
circumstance became a monster in
unbelievable and relatable ways however
in a series like Dragon Ball with a
protagonist like Goku Frieza has found
himself with a character arc that works
as a perfect counterbalance to that of
Goku making his negative flat mark the
perfect complement to Goku's positive
flat arc Frieza has and wishes to change
the world and characters around him for
the worse and keep your eye out when
Dragon Ball super returns to our screens
because I bet he still intends to
manipulate Broly for the worse Dragon
Ball is a fantastic series full of
incredible diverse and extreme
personalities with a world surrounding
the characters that is just as colorful
and extreme my
what this video was to outline why
purely despicable characters have a
place in fiction alongside their more
popular sympathetic and relatable
counterparts these wicked characters
captivate us disgust us and make us
cheer with their defeats so who knows
perhaps now you'll respect see the
merited and above all appreciate when a
character is written to be the
unsympathetic villain thanks for
watching
[Music]